with wei yi and prague uh  there we go uh magnus carlsen  finishing things off very smoothly with  some nice technique the pawn on a7 now  the king will wander across  to uh well e6 and f5  and and that's that's or f6 and that's  absolutely game over yeah let's see what  would  happen  there we go  and that's it  i'm sure there are other ways but this  looks this looks good enough as usual  the black king can't really leave these  two squares  this is the standard trick in such  structures not a lot of moves  h7 well if the king goes somewhere else  the rock moves with check  so i can always use two songs  to force his way way in  easy technical victory for the world  champion